alright guys we are here with Pascal I'm
super excited because I don't think a
lot of people know the intricacies of
what ledger does and how it works
so but before we get to that why don't
we just start with your background and
kind of how you got into crypto yeah hi
hi everyone so my background is actually
in advertising technology okay I
targeted my career in 2000 just after
the the crash of the internet bubble and
and I started by you know setting clicks
and advertising in banners and I built
my career into this my last company was
called credo we listed credo at the
Nasdaq in 2013 and it was listed for a
little both two billion dollars in
valuation so that was an amazing ride
you know starting from France and
building company everywhere in the world
from 15 people to a thousand and what
I've learned from advertising technology
is how to scale companies because
there's one thing that a tech companies
do well it's to scale and to become
global very quickly and after I left
quit EO in 2013 after the Nasdaq
introduction I was thinking of you know
opening my chakras to business and see
what's out there and you know when you
when you start from France and you build
a two billion dollar company there's you
know you know advertising technology is
pretty much done for you because the
probability that you will build another
successful business like that in the
same space is very low and also I was
getting frustrated by the gaff fest like
you know in advertising technology
what's very difficult is to build a
company where you have those big sharks
swimming around you and it's very tough
to build competitive products when
you're gigantic companies like these
competing with you and so you know I
thought like where can I go that I don't
have these Gaffa pressure and you know
what's new out there and Bitcoin in 2014
for me it was really like the horror a
moment or the Eureka moments where
suddenly you see that there are new
protocols that are very new not many
people working on these protocols yet
and and a lot of potential you know I
think that everybody that listening to
this already agrees with the potential
of crypto but in 2014 maybe wasn't as
easy to see and in 2008 even less but I
saw the potential and I thought wow this
is a great potential to really find so
many things that we do in terms of
transmitting values to one another and
you know peer-to-peer type of system and
all the good things that people like in
crypto but I also thought that it was a
great business opportunity to build a
company that could become really big
very global right away because Bitcoin
and crypto is a global phenomenon
you know from Paris where we have great
engineers and not competing with Google
and Facebook right away so this is why
I'm here
awesome what's the first time that you
ever heard about Bitcoin or crypto so
yeah it was in 2014 I was actually doing
I was an entrepreneur in residence with
Index Ventures in London and we were
doing these investment meetings and
Bitcoin you know it was a buzzword that
started popping in into the meetings and
you know at the beginning was like what
is Bitcoin and you know in the end is
like why not Bitcoin and the you know
index made a few investments way back
when and he was at the time with Bitcoin
was like skyrocketing to a thousand and
just before the mongos incident and yeah
this is when I was first exposed and I
met with was an amazing guy Vince's his
heiress that a lot of people know the
CEO of Zeppo and he pitched me or he
pitched like a group of people at index
like in five minutes Bitcoin and I was
like okay done like you know I believe
that guy and so he got me really excited
about the space and for me was a
no-brainer and the no-brainer it was a
no-brainer but a few I saw a few gaps
into Bitcoin and the two gaps that I saw
was data the lack of data the lack of
knowledge and for a guy like me like I
come from a non-technical background you
know I don't have a financial background
as well so you know for me it was hard
to understand at first so I thought data
and content was missing and security was
a big missing piece and after the
Mongoose incident he was very clear the
security governance was a was was a
critical piece where I think this
industry cannot go further if if we
don't fix it and that's what letter is
about we're about to fix this got it and
when you decide hey I'm gonna go into
crypto
did you know exactly what you wanted to
build where there are a couple of
different ideas you explored like walk
me through the process from you know
once this comes in okay I got it
I understand Bitcoin that's interesting
you start looking at different
opportunities you identify these two
areas how do you get from there to
starting ledger yeah so not this great
question so first I was lucky enough to
have liquidity from my previous company
so when you have liquidity you have time
to through to be a thinker and so so I
built my company called challenger deep
and challenger deep is the lowest point
on earth it's in the Mariana Trench ASIS
under the ocean and it's mainly
unexplored and for me was like the name
of my company was because I wanted to
explore that world like not knowing was
what was under there and knowing not
much and so I build the company before
knowing what to do and the first thing
that I did was data because coming from
the advertising world data is something
that we manipulates a lot so we we know
the value of data and so my first play
was through PL data and the company
actually now is called keiko so if I'm
challenger you called keiko and I've got
almost would be home who's the CEO and
running a team of 12 people and doing
great things in the market right now and
basically selling data like market data
- you know hedge funds and and and so on
and so forth
so that was my first idea but you know
when you build a company you actually
changes of success are very long and so
I projected myself into this business
thinking that I just wanted to invest
and be part of this revolution and
thinking that I would sort of buy coins
you know that was part of my investment
build my company that was a second part
but also invest in others people company
because the you know the possibility of
me succeeding with my own company was
very slim and so I thought like you know
let's not put all my eggs in the same
basket and that's also better on other
people that better know what they do and
so that was at the end of 2014 when I
met Elektra vague Nico Rebecca and the
founding team of ledger and this guy
pitched me security which I thought was
a big gap and they they were doing
something around the simcard because you
know I don't know if you know but the
sim card industry was invented in France
so actually in France we have all these
developers and people they're very
strong at building you know security
that is a combination of hardware and
software and that brings that is
protecting the banking secrets for the
past 20
years in the telecommunication secrets
as well and so when they pitch me the
simple idea of like taking that SIM card
technology and applying it to crypto I
thought you know this sounds like a
great idea and also this sounds like an
idea of you know this is why company
based in France got an edge and have
something to say to the market that is
very different and probably be really
good so you know it took me five minutes
to make an investment decision I told
Eric it's okay man here is like two
hundred thousand euros it was a seed
investment so it's my biggest investment
ever I said I give you two hundred
thousand euros but I want a board seat
because you know I want to be with you
guys and I want to also want to help you
and I want to know what's going on and
and at the time lucky me the team was
desperate for money so they gave me the
board seat without thinking about it but
but then I was the first investor I was
a triggered around so everyone followed
me so the first run was 1.4 million or
something like that apparently other
investors like so me investing like
crazy like a signal that ledger was good
but but ledger was good because
technology was good the team was good
and being at the board seat has been
amazing so I've been three years at the
company as an independent board member
and last year-and-a-half as the
president of company so really helping
with operation scaling and going to
market got it and when they first
pitched you what was the kind of product
or the idea what was it within a
building or was it something else
no the product and the idea was exactly
the same that we have right now so
what's your the Nano is that you see was
the original idea they they show me a
prototype at the time that looks nothing
like the Nano s and they were like this
is what we're gonna to do I'm like okay
it's ugly as hell but you know whatever
like you know people want to protect
value so I thought that having an
another device would make sense when a
lot of people say like you but why would
you have another device you have your
phone or your computer it's good enough
like you know software only is good like
nobody's going to go for another device
but actually what we found but I
believed in that vision and in this
theory what we found that for now
another device is cool but I also know
now which I didn't know at the time when
invested is
the core technology at Leger is not so
much the device is not the hardware it
is the operating system that sits at the
heart and this operating system has been
beautifully designed so it can operate
in any kind of hardware so I think that
the massive innovation of Leger is to to
have built a security platform that is
partially closed because we want to
protect the secret but also partially
open so any third party developer can
actually call now on later platform and
the Leger operating system can go in any
kind of hardware which is why we're able
to secure individuals that's what we do
is a ledger and an OS product which is
why we are able to secure enterprises
and b2b this is why we do with the
ledger vault for hedge funds family
offices law enforcement agencies like
anyone that holds coins and need
governance on top of security and easy
of you know to make it easy to use these
are the three things that we do and
finally we will secure objects because
objects will be connected connected to
block chains and objects in the future
have critical digital assets that need
protection and you can use later
technology in order to do that what's
your take on the current security
landscape right and the reason why I
asked this is I think most people who
aren't overly familiar with the crypto
industry they read these headlines that
are you know there's exchange hacks
there's people who are you know they get
hacked they lose bitcoins that you know
they do all this stuff what's actually
going on on the ground right what I like
the threats on the security side and
that we can get into kind of how you
guys actually use cold storage and
different things to kind of mitigate
those but one of those threats and
what's kind of that security landscape
today look it's a great question I think
number one crypto and those block chains
this is very new this is the first time
that we've created the digital assets
that is unique and because this digital
asset is unique it can be stolen very
easily so I think what Meg detector
energy absolutely great makes it also
very fragile if you think about digital
assets before like nobody can steal you
nobody can steal an mp3 from you like
better to steal a Bitcoin is a big
problem
and to steal like ten thousand Bitcoin
100 thousand Bitcoin that's also it's a
much bigger problem and you can you can
steal that in one transaction and if you
think about like assets and commodities
like anything you want cash gold to
steal anything at scale at this type of
scale is very difficult like you know
when was the last time a bank was hacked
like two billion dollars in cash that
they never recovered like it doesn't
really exist how do you steal two
billion dollars worth of gold of oil the
only way of actually doing this at scale
is to have an army and to invade a
country that's that's how you do it but
with crypto you can be a hacker in your
living room and you know somewhere
anywhere in the world and you know you
hack exchanges every day so the stuff
that we have is exchanges every day lose
2.7 million dollars so it's big number
we feel and they've lost so far 1.8
billion dollars Wow and we think we
believe that it's because in the old
world and the new world being crypto but
in the old world security is taken for
granted because you cannot really lose
value that much you cannot really use
money again you cannot lose gold like if
you give your goal to UBS like you know
nothing is going to happen again because
it's difficult to steal gold like how
are you gonna do that you bring trucks
like you know guys with guns like it's
very difficult but with Bitcoin and
crypto in general is very easy to steal
so but but because we're coming from
this world where everything is secure I
don't think that has not been a
mentality shift yet for most of the
players in the space and you would think
you know people should take security
seriously because we're being hacked
every day but actually no and when I
read stuff about the new technology that
is being deployed today and everyone
talks about cold storage like it's a
great technology
I mean cold storage is not a technology
it's nothing like you know you you can
put your keys on a piece of paper let's
talk about right so let's describe what
is cold storage right to start with a
very simple mode I can explain your cold
storage in one sentence you you write
your private keys on a piece of paper
you put it in the book and you put it in
your library at home okay that's called
storage because it's the actual private
key that is not in any you
former shape connected to the internet
right okay and so what are the different
ways right now that people are doing
cold storage right there's what I would
consider there's custodians right so
basically you give your private keys to
somebody else and they hold them for you
mm-hmm there is self cold storage where
you put your crypto on a device and
you're doing this yourself
what's the pros and cons between those
two things this the self cold storage or
custody versus the use of a custodian
service I don't think I would I would
put it like that I think okay the main
difference right now in the market is
the technology difference and I'm sorry
that I will advertise for four ledger
but but I think that we have a
technology approach that is very
different from what the market is doing
so most of the markets whether it's a
custodian shape or self caster and shape
like that doesn't really matter but like
the technology to protect the private
keys like most of the market says we
cannot be connected online because we
don't have enough security and so we're
gonna put everything offline and the day
that we need to do a transaction we're
gonna you know send someone to check
what is offline and actually to bring it
back online and which is why it's very
inefficient which is why every solution
that uses this type of technology so
again it's not really technology it's
just like you know putting a computer in
the darkroom it's not technology for me
but you need to go from cold to hot this
is why you have a 48 hours delay if you
want to have your money like you cannot
do a transaction in real time which
which is sitting with us will we bring
this technology to the market that is
not a new technology actually it's a
technology that's been used by the
banking industry for a long time
so typically if we think about the
enterprise industry we've developed
everything our operating system is
ported on to an HSM a hardware security
module ok the HSM protect the private
keys and through the devices that we
have the ledger blue you can actually
sign on the HSM and the communication
between the ledger blue and the HSM is
secured the HSM have been designed to be
online all the time you actually don't
need to bring them offline so the HSM
acts as a protection of the private key
so horn before I keep going I want
clarify this so people understand the
cold storage is secure based on what it
does right but there's some downsides to
it right the ability to go from cold
storage to hot yeah can take a while
right so the the nature of that's why
secure and just slow etc well you guys
have developed it's something that is
secure but also doesn't have some of
those downsides that true cold storage
provides exactly right and so today you
have two separate pieces of hardware if
I understand this correctly right
let's talk about the actual ledger
itself what what is that what do you
mean that yourself the like the USB the
USB I'm not sure I'm following you not
the hsm the the other hardware device
the the ledger boot
yes yes it's a it's an auto-da-fé
ocation device okay acts as a
notification device in the center
private key is not in the ledger blue
the private key what what is on the
ledger blue it's just a part of the
private key because okay let me take a
step back so basically what happened is
we are four in the room right now and we
all run a hedge fund okay and we have
100 million dollars in bitcoins okay who
has access to the private key I don't
trust you enough so only you has access
to to the hundred million and actually
your LPS everyone is going to ask you
you know what's the governance on these
on these coins so actually what you want
is a set of rules so we know how we can
operate these this 100 million and who's
gonna have access to the coins like okay
and so typically if we need to make a
transaction of both ten million we have
agreed and missed relatively that all of
all of us for need to sign the
transaction for example okay if it's
below 1 million then only you can sign
etc etc all these rules are coded and
enforced by the hardware so basically we
can now sort of have any coin in our
hedge fund and any coin all the
governor's rule will be run by the
hardware so some coins as you know
support multi signature at the protocol
level other coins don't but actually in
our technology doesn't really matter
because all the multi signature and all
the rules are enforced by the hsm and by
the technology but I give you another
example why
being online sort of all the time while
still being secure is very important and
why coal storage in many cases won't
work in the future how do you stack
coins when you're in cold storage you
can't it's a big limitation of cold
storage so typically all these companies
that are doing cold storage on one side
and then they go Hut the day that you
want to take your coins they're gonna
have to come up with a different
solution because cold storage is not
going to work for this our technology
sort of adapts to whatever evolution of
the market is coming because as all the
rules and the security is provided by
it's actually the combination of the
hardware and the software every layer on
top you can you can you can bring onto
onto the platform so typically right now
we're developing you know proof of stake
and delegated proof of stake as new
protocols that would be implemented both
in our hardware well @n in the vault
solution so if you work with us you'll
be able to stake your coins or delegate
the staking of your coins to to a third
party and so how does the hsm right
let's say you go back to your example
with four people at a hedge fund with a
hundred million dollars in bitcoin it's
sitting on the ledger blue how does that
piece of technology actually when all
four people say okay I want to sign off
on this what what is the user experience
for signing off to to get those private
keys actually move some percentage of
the crypto the experience I mean like
what would we experience yes so we all
say okay let's do it you know we get to
HSM and what do we do
yeah so it's a SAS product right now so
you wouldn't be getting the HSM what
you'll be getting is a part of our team
coming to your office showcasing your
product explaining to you how the
platform works and you will do the the
key ceremony so what is very important
that you do the management of the keys
the HSM you will never see unless you
want it on premise but that's a
different discussion but let's say they
use our SAS product we take care of the
HSM we take care of the technology and
we just come to help you set up your
identification devices and there are
different type of identification devices
there are some for the administrators
and some for the operators so typically
what's happening is you cannot operate
the phone and administrate the phone at
the same time
you know your CFO and you know some
people in your company or in our
electrons would be the one setting the
rules and then traders will be the one
sort of spending the money if you if you
know what I mean and so and again all
these rules are enforced by the hardware
and and the hardware provide many other
good things like segregation of accounts
audit trails etc etc that you cannot
really get with software only okay and
then who's buying these right are these
mostly retail individual investors or
they you know larger organizations
enterprises a mix like where are you
seeing most of the interest today in the
hardware products family offices hedge
funds big institutional players like
everyone needs technology at the heart
what you have to understand is right now
when we say let your vote we are
showcasing a product and success product
however you can sort of strip down our
technology right down to the operating
system so in theory anyone in the
industry can work with us and work from
like sort of the the bare HSM with the
operating system sitting on top and you
could code everything on top of that so
we have various discussions in the
marketplace some people just need the
product like the SAS product because
they want the end-to-end product that
does everything from them and other
people have like more complex security
schemes and they want just the hardware
and the software Pledger running at the
heart a very thing that they do in terms
of their security but then they build
their own applications on top so in
reality you could use the operating
system and rebuild everything on top
including your blockchain explorers etc
etc and or you can start using different
bricks that ledger provide to you got it
and then what can you tell me about the
company in terms of number of customers
revenue units sold like what uh what
data points can you share with us we
have many data points better the more
you share the the happier I'll be
exactly look we we sold one point four
million units of our legend nos in what
time period since we started it yeah
a lot desolates we had a killer Black
Friday so interestingly as the price was
plunging down you know our sales
remained very strong so we believe that
the price is not everything and that
there's still a lot of interest in the
communities and a lot of people still
joining the the crypto market so you
know what the numbers were for Black
Friday what the numbers I like the
number of units you sold I know but I
won't disclose ok that's [ __ ] no
worries but good and now actually I can
give you a referential quite similar to
2017 Black Friday which we sell that
yeah wow that is pretty impressive ok so
a little less to be fair but but close
like not to a factor of like five times
less actually on par like you know it's
sort of fun part so that's one number we
ship those products in more than hundred
sixty-five countries which is also cool
number meaning like everyone in the
planet is doing crypto there's not one
dark country for us like where nobody
orders our products like you know it is
a very global business yeah yeah a very
global business when it comes through
the volt product we've already signed in
or on boarded 30 clients so that's good
congratulations and Counting we have
more than 500 prospects and and again
it's a very global business we've we
have this week up in our office in New
York
I mean announced that we're opening the
office in New York Demetrios is now our
global have a global head of old based
out of New York and we have a strong
team here but we equally open an office
in Hong Kong to cover a pack so for us
it's all about you know being a global
tech provider for this industry and
interestingly enough like we have great
conversations in Europe in the US in
APAC everywhere same discussions so you
know to to you know to testify that the
crypto market whether it's retail or b2b
is truly global got it and where do you
guys want to go next right so you've got
a product that I think people like they
are buying obviously they feel like it
secures their crypto assets
today it is mostly focused on support of
crypto currencies how many do you guys
support that's a great question
we have a life page to say how many we
support and like a lot a lot okay yeah
and do you support all like ERC 20
tokens so when these token high
securities and stuff come out you also
be able to do that or is it more
specific around each individual token no
I mean the idea is to support everything
but the bigger idea I think is for us
it's it's an open platform I mean part
of the platform is open so the latest
tokens that that we are supporting I
have actually like the applications I've
actually been quoted by third-party
developers oh very cool that code on top
of our platform and then of course we we
vet and we approve the application just
to make sure it's running smoothly on
our operating system but technically
anyone can develop their own app so any
community that has a new coin and the
one that nuke want to be supported by
Ledger today can actually do it they
join our slack for developer and and you
have a team there that is helping them
design the code got it and then you know
five years from now what what is your
hope for Ledger in terms of what does it
look like is it still a security company
and you guys have just gotten bigger and
more global do you envision adding other
business lines or kind of other areas to
expand into what's that look like you
know kind of five years out yeah
so there is an another business line
that we're already doing which is
Machines IOT so we call it IOT right now
we didn't find a better name but you
know I think the world because of crypto
the world we just shifted into a new
world and this is the world of critical
digital assets there are many digital
asset that you don't want to lose now I
give you one example that has nothing to
do with crypto but if you're if you have
a pacemaker and that pacemaker becomes
an connected object and is connected
online for many good reasons like you
know your doctor gets a live feed of
your heart etc etc you really don't want
that pacemaker to be hacked and stopped
because then you die and until very
recently this was not even a problem and
so there is a big joke in IOT to say
there is no as the s of security doesn't
exist in IOT because we've all seen like
the Silicon Valley episode
where you know hi ot get sacked etc but
this is reality many IO T's objects have
been hacked and so it's not just IOT is
to say that those critical those
critical digital objects are coming to
life now you know crypto is one but like
your heart being hacked imagine like
autonomous cars driving in New York and
suddenly someone hacks into the system
and gets all the cars to crash you know
in in a world and kill everyone you know
there is that and so the the vision of
ledger is we're going to be the company
to secure those critical digital assets
so if you work in a company and you have
that problem and you're send paranoid
like you're gonna come to us and make
sure that your security scheme is
actually the best that you can be and
today we believe that for today and for
the next five years we probably have the
best technology that is sort of reliable
always online protected by hardware and
software and that can be integrated in
any kind of any kind of device because
the hard thing with security you know we
come from that industry and we have
strong security engineers within the
company the difficulty with security and
the way it's been done in the past is
you secure object by object so every
object is gonna have one security scheme
and sort of one software and one
operating system running into it and we
are sort of building the platform to
secure it all so that's going to be
interesting and the interesting thing is
third-party developers will be able to
code on top and so that's very new in
security as well usually security I
don't tell you what I do you trust me
that I'm good and and it will work trust
me you know in our case and it's not
exactly true booting and then you go
through certification etc in our case
you will go through certification but
also part of the platform will be open
for third parties to develop on top with
the certification that is going to be
secured so that opens many very exciting
opportunities and possibilities for the
future where anything will be able to be
secured with the ledger operating system
and applications will be whatever
they're the coders and make them yeah
it's fascinating that you guys are going
outside of crypto right because all
these other kind of you know critical
digital devices
the pacemaker makes a lot of sense what
other types of products fall in that
category
you might not even be addressing them
yet but just like what are the other
types of products and that
mission-critical digital devices yeah I
mean the pacemaker example is to say
that it doesn't need to be crypto like
whatever has value and our value
different value has to be protected very
securely in the future but I can give
you an another example that has more to
do with crypto and it is also very
interesting and shows why crypto is
gonna have a strong impact on our
societies the tokenization of energy
whether it's a molecule of you know of
oil electricity water like all of this
is very interesting because energy is
being traded every day and yet the way
that we account for that trading is is
very light like the technologies are not
great
so typically we started the partnership
with a utility company in France where
Leger is building the technology to to
to be a certificate of origin of of the
energy so the way it works is like every
windmill I'm gonna make it simple every
windmill in Europe at some point we have
a ledger element on it and when the
windmill will produce one megawatt of
green energy it will go through the
ledger device that will authenticate the
fact that is one megawatt of green
energy and send that information onto a
blockchain to produce a green token then
then we'll be able to be traded by
traders so if you want to make sure to
buy green energy you will buy those
tokens it's really what you're doing
there's you're not only validating the
amount of energy but you're validating
the quality or the type of energy that
is being being created and I'm guessing
that you can do things like geography
time of day you know I don't know what
type of regulation carbon credit you
know all kinds of things that you can
actually code into that token based on
your kind of point of generation device
that that's generating that data yeah
completely yeah very very cool
okay and then what's the areas of crypto
specifically that you think are really
interesting but maybe people aren't
building companies in right so so
obviously you got involved in Ledger
because somebody pitched you on an idea
you got excited about it you invest in
admission join the company what are
those areas today that you're like man
if somebody pitched me on X Y or Z I
think that would be really interesting
to see somebody build a huge company
there
so I think that still lots need to be
done in data like you know with all the
love data I love it data is cool because
and especially in the crypto world all
this data is available you can really do
a lot of cool things with it I don't
think you know companies are doing
enough you know my company Keiko I think
he's doing good right now but I think we
could definitely do better I think
there's a big plain data and when you
see where the data companies are at
right now I think it's good but could do
better so if someone would came with a
grand vision of building this big data
company I think would make a lot of
sense for the industry because there's
so many products that you can build
indexes you know you know how to
forecast the price like you know a lot
of intelligence on on the data that you
that the industry should build so so I'm
working hard on that matter also with
Keiko but but if someone has super cool
ideas I'm willing to to look at it and
to invest but I think data is it's gonna
be key for this industry I think there
are cool projects coming I think you
know delegated proof of stake proof of
stake like you know we're gonna watch
this very closely because it's an
entering intriguing a part of the space
everything they side-chains we I don't
know lightning liquid all this is is
very cool so companies that are working
on lightning you know we look at them a
lot because we believe it's important
for the future of this industry and I'm
curious about atomic swaps you know why
personally I don't know it just right
now it doesn't work so well but he feels
that if it did it would be important it
could be important you know it was
finally you know you know swapping those
coins like you know is that having to go
through an exchange a centralized
exchange etcetera etcetera everything
that is going towards the essential
ization I think is interesting
everything that goes towards
centralization and rebuilding the old
economy was with these new tokens I
think is less interesting personally but
thing is fair all right before I end I
usually do a like a rapid-fire round of
questions and then I end with letting
you ask me a question so think about
that while I fire some of these off
um what uh what do you think the most
important company in crypto is other
than ledger another great company in
crypto the most important the most
important company in crypto other than
ledger well so man that's a very tough
question and now I'm gonna sound like
you know I'm late Germania I can ledger
only but I can't say ledger I can't say
that I want a ledger I want to say can I
ask you the question before you know why
think about this one okay so you wanna
ask okay alright you ask me the question
why yeah so the question is uh you know
what is very exciting like because you
interview a lot of people etc so what
seems to be like 2019 trend like fair to
say one trend what do you think it is
it's hard to say what the trend is I'm
not gonna try to call the trend I'm
gonna tell you what I'm personally
interested in based on conversations
I've had with people and what I think it
more and more people are shifting
towards or looking at right I think it's
fair I think it the timings hard that's
why that's why I'm kind of answering it
this way the state-backed digital
currencies I think are going to come I
don't know if they will be successful or
not but I think most people are either
oblivious or they're kind of writing
them off as oh those aren't gonna work I
don't think we've yet seen a well
capitalized well coordinated
nation-state say that's watching I think
that's pretty interesting I'm gonna
create a digital currency that looks
similar to those digital decentralized
currencies you guys have but we're gonna
kind of back it and use it for you know
monetary policy and things like that in
the way that were used to central bank's
doing so I think we'll see more of that
on a 12 24 36 months but but that'll be
an interesting thing to look at another
area that I'm personally interested in I
see more and more people looking at is
blockchain bonds or smart bonds so the
idea of taking you know kind of
traditional fixed income type assets but
creating digitally native bonds right so
good that they're actually issued on the
blockchain and all the things that you
can do with that and around making
faster cheaper more global more secure
et cetera
and the third thing and this sounds
pretty stupid but but I actually think
the trend of 2019 is just gonna be
building sustainable businesses right
and so if you think of 17 was like the
year of the ico everyone
it was fundraising and that was like the
the finish line for a lot of these
projects was let's make this big
announcement about fundraising
then dozen 18 it was the like retraction
back to naive insanity but like a true
bear market right and I think you know
we're started we're recording his
bitcoins that like four thousand dollars
so we're like we're around the
capitulation point for many people and I
think you know a lot of tours got washed
out etc but I think what happens through
the second half of eighteen and going
into 19 is the real entrepreneurs
they're not shaken by any of this
they're still building they're going to
focus on building companies that have
cashflow profitability they're gonna get
monetized in going public or acquired
and and you're gonna see some really big
kind of behemoths emerge we probably
can't tell who they are until you know
21 22 23 but they're getting built today
writing into 2019 and so I think that's
gonna be a trend in hindsight we're
gonna look like I said Oh 2019 July the
year that a lot of those companies got
built which i think is a good thing and
needed by the industry yeah so I agree
with everything you said and actually
it's a great segue to so I can give you
my answer any question so I think right
now I don't sort of rate anyone
including ledger so the question is hard
because he's like oh who do you think is
great like I think we're all average
right now and an anklet ledger into this
I think there is so much that we can do
I mean what service did you open
recently that is doing crypto where you
were like oh my god like you know this
is gonna change my life not many like
you most ever sees a very clunky I have
a list of improvements on our own
services that is you know so long and we
keep adding things etc so like you say I
think the bear market is an exceptional
moment for for this industry I mean
because it forces you to do the right
things and to actually build great
products that make a difference and when
you can look at them and actually be
proud and so I think no one is doing an
A+ job right now like you know there are
a lot of a lot of big companies and and
we are thriving to become ace so I think
a few teams are doing some really good
solid things in the market but we're not
quite where the market needs to be and
no one has a cuter product right now and
again you know we we think ledger has
cool technology but we also realize the
amount of work that we still need to do
in order to become the company that we
want to become and so I think that
everyone is sort of like that I mean all
the big companies are sort of like in in
in that game like you know they're doing
okay but they're not doing amazing or I
don't think anyone is doing amazing but
but that's a cheap way of answering a
question so now I gotta tell you like
who I like apart from from ledger but I
thought cryptokeys was really cool I
think it was an amazing moment you know
broke the theorem you know protocol and
and having like this these crypto
kitties remind me of my childhood with
the tamagushi etc I thought it was a
cool crypto experience I loved it
what's uh what's the most important book
you've ever read The Lord of the Rings
why why because because it's a fantastic
book to to travel actually to to books a
lot of the Rings and foundation by
Asimov foundation by Asimov actually is
a book that helps me every day so the
other rings because I like to go in to
evade in different countries etc you
know I think not what burner needs that
not that I'm the best entrepreneur
planet but like you know I think like to
be able to protect yourself in a new
world and that's what Lord of the Ring
does really well but equally as
amorphous foundation is an amazing book
and it's something that helps me
everyday because they have this thing of
and I read it in French I'm sorry but
Seco history where they're
mathematicians that do these equations
to predict the future and I think it's a
very interesting idea and so they
predict the future and sometimes the
future doesn't quite happen the way they
predicted it so they start the equation
again and predict another future and so
for me I always look at
my life in the next five years next 10
years I always have a plan for five
years ten years after that it's too long
because you have a lot of accidents that
are happening and so azimoff actually in
Tolkien where strong readings I love it
as I love it
let's admit that there's aliens which is
a non cryptic question right so aliens
exist somewhere out there in the world
most of the times they are presented as
human comparables right but you never
really see alien animals or alien pets
do you think that those exist or do you
think it's all just one homogeneous
species out there as aliens so
interestingly I read recently that
octopuses were actually not from this
planet there's actually real theory what
[Music]
yeah dr. puss in the ocean yep octopus
in the ocean there's actually very
strong and academic research that's been
done on the octopus and you know some
people have the theory that the octopus
could be an alien form because of the
way it's like I don't have the I don't
remember the details but because of the
way like octopuses are which is very
different from any other living spacing
living creature on the planet you know
what you just made me think of and I've
never thought about this before a lot of
times people say you know or the aliens
already here right meaning are they here
on earth I've never thought about or the
aliens here but they just live under the
sea yeah and so but apparently is
someone that has this theory of the you
know octopus being like a grater from
the space that was actually dropped on
earth because they have such a structure
that they believe it's it's it's too
different to be actually from here so
yeah maybe that's the wildest answer
anyone said I love that answer and my
wife hates octopus over like and when I
told her that she was like told you so
disgusting anymore like you can't be
from this planet she's got a deep fear
do they do they serve octopus for food
and in France they do actually own a
restaurant in Paris uh-huh and we do
serve octopus is like despair okay so
she doesn't like it hasn't tried
all right maybe well I'll come to Paris
and we'll go and lead some octopus
million you invited yeah yeah I'd love
to tell people I ate a lien that'd be
great all right man no thank you so much
for coming this is awesome I'm a big fan
of what you guys are doing that ledger
and so we'll have to do this again as
you guys keep growing sure thank you for
having me absolutely